foreign
with some of your social media questions
Here Charlie from Facebook has something
for us what does an uncluttered mind
feel like
oh and I'm an uncluttered mind is
untethered from the past and the future
so
where is a cluttered mine it exists not
in the present moment there's a paradox
about this because there is no present
moment because soon as I say present
moment that is now the past right or I'm
thinking about something that's going to
happen five minutes from now five days
from now five years from now that's also
taking me out of the present moment or
I'm thinking about something that
happened yesterday I can't believe I
screwed this up I should have said this
differently oh if I would have just
answered the job interview question this
way then my life would be perfect now
right and so we're talking today about
psychological clutter which I think
happens at the intersection of mental
clutter and and the sort of emotional
clutter the The Head and the Heart
creates all of this internal clutter
that's going on and Dr deloni you have a
lot of experience talking to people on
the radio about this sort of anxiety
that leads to the cluttered mind as
Charlie uh illuminates here what are
some of your thoughts on the cluttered
line and what is it feel like so the
word that comes to mind is peace and it
occurred to me a few months ago
I think we've lost context of what that
even means anymore and my granddad uh
World War II vet he fought Nazis
and he came
um home with started a small family and
he knew peace was not that right he had
a very Stark understanding of what peace
was and was not and then were two or
three generations removed now and pieces
like we were just talking off air like
it's 73 and I want it to be 71 and I'm
uncomfortable right and we then
pathologized
feeling not good and so every not good
feeling is something needs to be solved
he ended up in a rabbit hole so when
someone's asked what does a an
uncluttered mind feel like it feels like
peace it feels like your shoulders are
dropped and it feels like
um not that everything's perfect a great
example is
um my cousin died a few months ago and
um man he lived a a great life
my wife and I had the the the great
privilege of going to his funeral flying
there and we had the privilege of just
being sad because we had saved up money
we had a special account just for these
kind of moments we had time off from
work we were able to just go be sad and
so we were at peace even in a tough time
so an uncleared mind is one that is just
relationally spiritually financially
it's at peace
and the the perfect thing is fascinating
because we had a gal on I wasn't
Catherine shuffler uh Catherine Morgan
schaffler yeah she wrote this book on
perfectionism and completely changed my
idea of what perfect literally means but
also how that is applicable to our
everyday lives so perfect comes from the
Latin root per and for Sarah so
completely done so something doesn't
need to be Flawless to be completely
done if I were to die today my life
would have been perfect because then
it's completely done and so when we
often conflate peace with comfort then
Everything feels imperfect because it's
not Flawless and then we moralize
everything right good and bad are
emotions that exist in the cluttered
head of the beholder and so when I say
oh I'm uncomfortable because it's cold
it's 50 degrees and I'm cold and that is
a bad thing we even moralize the weather
we can pathologize everything and make
it feel as though because it's not to my
exact liking it's not Flawless therefore
it must be bad yeah when I think about
an uncluttered mind I think about the
words of David Allen who says the mind
is for having ideas not holding ideas
but when we use the mind to hold ideas
we compromise its ability to have them
the mind is there to generate insight
and creativity but we often use it as a
receptacle to place our plans and our
worries and all those sorts of things
and so you know you are uncluttered when
you are experiencing that generative
quality of mind when your mind is a
force for ideas for creativity when you
can access what's within you and your
mind is an asset on the other hand if
your mind is just sort of like oh man
what am I going to do about this what am
I about that and you feel that anxiety
you feel that stress you're cluttered
because you're using your mind to hang
on to things to hold on to things and
it's
it's its proper function as being
overwhelmed by all of these other things
yeah yeah to to add to that TK so yes an
uncluttered mind will make you feel more
peaceful but when you feel more peaceful
now you can deal with those
uncomfortable feelings when they arise
so when you have uh uh you know when
you've let go of all of this um
expectations or hopes or disappointments
or whatever it is when you have sadness
come up or you have anger come up like
there's space for you to address that
rather than let that emotion uh run
ragged with you and I think we often ask
how do I get there how do I unclutter my
mind that's very similar to asking how
do I declutter my home because we all we
never start with the the how to we start
with the Y2 we start with the question
how might your life be better with less
or TK often rephrases it how might your
life be more with less and when people
hear that they think less stuff okay
that's part of it but what about less
mental clutter fewer thoughts that are
constantly pinballing around my head and
telling me I'm inadequate I'm
insufficient I'm incomplete well that is
a a clever mind yeah how often do we sit
in the shower and have imaginary
conversations with people that we will
never have in real life right and we
always might drop all of them we win all
of them we're like yeah
never gonna have that conversation if I
saw the prison and I'd tell you you
wouldn't tell him anything right and our
bodies don't know the difference between
a real war and an imagined War it just
goes to war and so man what a different
way to live and if you think about like
budgeting your money or looking at your
home the spontaneous combustion we
talked about what if you just picked 30
days and said I'm only going to think
positive thoughts about my spouse and my
kids and my co-workers and that's what
I'm going to spill spend my time and
I'll walk through my living room guys
and I'll just say out loud nope and my
wife just rolls her eyes now because she
knows I was starting an imaginary
conversation and I'm just stopping this
I'm stopping it and what if we paid as
much attention to the thoughts in our
head as we do the stuff in our house
your whole physiology changes everything
about your body changes if you can
capture your mind man did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free